في يوم 25 اكتوبر سنه 1985 وتحديدا في
تمام الساعه 11:45 بتوقيت دبي اقلع التيار
الباكستاني فضل غني بيان بطائره ايرباص من
طراس اي 300 من مطار دبي لمدينه كراتش
الباكستانيه في رحله تاريخيه الرحله دي
كانت لحظه ميلاد شركه ضخمه جدا ما كانش في
حد يمكن يتخيل وقتها انها هتغير مفهوم
الطيران التجاري في العالم للابد وهي شركه
طيران الامارات التابعه لاماره دبي اللي
حصل وقتها ان حاكم دبي ورئيس مجلس وزراء
الامارات الشيخ محمد بن راشد ال مكتوم جنب
موريس فنجان المدير الاداري للاتحاد النقل
الجوي الوطني لدبي دناتا وقال له عاوزين
ناس شركه طيران تقدر في المستقبل تخدم خطط
الاماره في التحول لمركز تجاري وسياحي
عالمي الكلام ده وقتها كان خيال علمي لان
الشركه بدات براسبه البسيط حتى بمعايير
الزمن وقتها هو عشره مليون دولار بس وما
اشتروش اي طيارات في الاول
انما اجره طيارتين من الخطوط الجويه
الباكستانيه وحطوا شعار طيران الامارات
عليهم كل ده ما كانش يوحي ان في حاجه
كبيره هتحصل لكن اللي ما كانش حد متوقعه
حصل بالفعل طيران الامارات حاليا هي واحده
من اكبر شركات الطيران في العالم بتدير
اسطول مكون من 269 طياره وبيتحرك رحلاتها
ل158 وجهه في 85 دوله وهي تالت افضل شركه
طيران في العالم في 2022 في تصنيف سكاي
تراكس لافضل شركات الطيران في العالم
والشركه دايما في الخمسه الاوائل في
التصنيف ده بقى لها سنين طويله نجاح طيران
الامارات كان استثنائي فعلا ونفس النموذج
الاستثنائي ده نقدر نشوفه في قطر اللي
اطلقت شركه الخطوط الجويه القطريه بعد
طيران الامارات بثمان سنين بس وبدات
مسيرتها برضو بطاريتين و75 موظف ولكنها
حاليا بتمتلك 263 طياره وبتصير رحلات
لاكتر من 150 وجه عالميه وهي افضل شركه
طهران في العالم في تصنيف سكاي تراكس
العالمي النجاح الكبير لطيران الامارات
والقطريه اغرى اماره ابو ظبي انها تطلق
شركه هي كمان باسم طيران الاتحاد والشركه
حققت نجاح ما يقلش عن اخواتها الاتنين
والتلات شركات بقوا معروفين عالميا باسم
الثلاثه الخليجين الكبار
وتفوقوا على دول وشركات كتير بدات قبلهم
ومنها شركات عربيه عريقه زي شركه مصر
للطيران اللي تاسست سنه 1932 وشركه الخطوط
السعوديه اللي تاسست سنه 1945 وطوران
الخليج البحرينيه اللي تاسست سنه 1950 من
اوائل الالفينات ولحد اللحظه وعلى مدار
اكتر من 20 سنه الثلاثه الكبار سيطروا على
سوق الطيران في المنطقه ودخلوا في
المنافسه ما بينهم وبين الشركات الامريكيه
والاوروبيه لاستقطاب المسافرين الدوليين
وتقديم افضل الخدمات باحسن الاسعار
وتقريبا الكل اعتقد ان السوق قفل على كده
مش مساحه لمنافس جديد لكن المملكه العربيه
السعوديه قررت تنزل السوق بتقولها واعلنت
في منتصف الشهر اللي فات مارس 2023 عن
اطلاق شركه طيران جديده باسم طيران الرياض
وعلى خلاف اخواتها فمن الواضح كده ان
الشركه السعوديه هتبدا بدايه كبيره ومش
هتنتظر كتير علشان تكون منافس حقيقي في
السوق المره دي احنا مش هنبدا بطيارتين
ولا ثلاثه ولا حتى عشره ولكن ب 72 طياره
من طراز بوينج 7.87
مخصصه للمسافات الطويله اشتريتهم المملكه
ب 37 مليار دولار في خامس اكبر طلبيه في
تاريخ شركه بوينج الامريكيه وهي طلبيه
فازت الشركه بها بعد منافسه شرسه مع
غريمتها الاوروبيه شركه الباص من المتوقع
ان طيران الرياض هتبدا عملها رسميا سنه
2025 علشان تربط في البدايه العاصمه
السعوديه ب 100 وجه حول العالم انطلاقا من
مطار الملك خالد في الرياض ولا هيتم
توسعته علشان يلاقي النشاطه طموحات الشركه
الجديده الكلام ده يخلينا نسال شويه اسئله
مهمه جدا جدا تخص مستقبل صناعه الطيران في
المنطقه والعالم كله زي مثلا اللي خلى
شركات الطيران الخارجيه ناجحه كده ويا ترى
النجاح ده قابل للتكرار في حاله السعوديه
وليه المملكه قررت تطلق شركه طيران جديده
بعد كل السنين دي ويا ترى السعوديه عامله
شركتها علشان تنافس شركات الطيران
الخارجيه التانيه ولا في اهداف اوسع من
كده للقصه دي دي عينه من الاسئله المهمه
اللي هنجاوب عليها في حلقه النهارده بس
قبل ما نبدا بفكركم بالاشتراك في القناه
بفكركم برضو ان كل حلقاتنا اللي فاتت
مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه فما تنسوش
تشاركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب تعرفوهم
علينا انا اشرف ابراهيم
[موسيقى]
والوحده الوطنيه لمكافحه جرائم تكنولوجيا
العاليه في المملكه المتحده هتلاقوا رابط
تحت الفيديو في تعليقات فيسبوك لخدمات
الامن السيبراني اللي يقدروا يساعدوك
ويحموا اعمالك بها قبل ما نتكلم عن شركه
الطيران السعوديه الجديده لازم نجاوب على
سؤال مهم جدا هو ايه سر نجاح شركات
الطيران الخارجيه عموما يعني ايه الوصفه
اللي هتاخدها السعوديه من الاماراتيين
والقطريين وهتنفذها في طيران الرياض
وتحاول تطورها علشان تحقق اهدافها الطموحه
علشان نجاوب على السؤال ده خلونا نقسم
شركات الطيران لنوعين رئيسيات النوع الاول
هو الشركات اللي بتشتغل بنموذج التوصيل
المباشر
وده معناه ببساطه انك بتركب طيارتك من بلد
اقامتك او عملك لوجهتك بشكل مباشر بدون
محطات وسيطه ده هيكون مشوار بسيط لو انت
ساكن في مدينه راسيه مهمه ورايح لمدينه
تانيه مهمه قريبه وفيها حركه جويه نشطه
بين المدينتيان يعني رايح من لباريس مثلا
او من القاهره للرياض فانت غالبا مش هتحس
بمشاكل مع نموذج الطيران ده لكن المشاكل
هتبدا تحس بها لما المسافات تطول شويه او
السفر يكون بين مدن غير رئيسيه علشان نوضح
القصه دي خليني اضرب لكم مثال بسيط جدا
لنفترض ان في شركه طيران عايزه تصير رحلات
جويه بين مجموعه من الوجهات الاوروبيه زي
لندن وباريس وروما ومجموعه من الوجهات
الاسيويه زي شغله هاي وبكيني وسنغافوره لو
هنطلع الرحلات دي بنظام الاتصال المباشر
فده معناه اننا محتاجين رحله من كل مدينه
من مدن الاوروبيه التلاته لكل مدينه
اسيويه والعكس وطبعا ده محتاج اسطول
طائرات كبير وطرازات معينه من الطائرات
اللي تقدر تطير بشكل متصل لساعات كبيره ده
غير التكلفه المرتفعه للرحلات دي اما لو
مش عاوز تدفع كتير فساعتها ما لكش خيار
غير انك تلبس في رحله متعدده التوقفات في
واحده من الطيارات الصغيره ودي رحله بتكون
طويله جدا ومجهده واشبه بيته بيس نقل عام
هيلففك محطات البلد كلها قبل ما يوصلك
مكانك البديل اللي اوجدته شركات الطيران
عشان تحل المعضله دي هو نموذج المركز
والمحيط او ما يعرف به
والاسم متاخد من شكل الاطارات بتاعه العجل
من خلال النموذج ده احنا هننقل المسافرين
من المدن الاوروبيه لنقطه مشتركه وهي
المركز واللي هتكون في حالتنا دبي او
الدوحه او ابو ظبي وبكده هنجمع كل
الاوروبيين اللي محتاجين يسافروا للمدن
الاسيويه في مكان واحد ومن هناك هنطلع
طياره واحده بس لكل وجهه من وجهات والعكس
بالظبط في الاتجاه التاني الكلام ده زي ما
حضراتكم شايفين مش بس بيقلل عدد خطوط
الطيران والطائرات المطلوبه واستهلاك
الوقود وبيسهل تغطيه وجهات اكتر لكنه كمان
بيقلل جدا تكلفه الرحلات وبيخلي جداولها
اكثر مرونه النموذج ده شركات الطيران
الخليجيه ما اخترعتوش لكنها استفادت منه
بشكل ما حدش عمله غيرها علشان تقدم نفسها
كقوه عظمى في صناعه الطيران العالميه لكن
كلمه السر اللي خلت الشركات الخارجيه
قادره تستفيد من النموذج ده بالشكل رهيب
ده هي الجغرافيا الجغرافيا يا جماعه هي
اللي بتتحكم في التلات عوامل الرئيسيه
اللي بتحدد نجاح اي شركه طيران واي نموذج
عمل وهم الوقت والتكلفه وحيويه الطرق
الجويه والمراكز اللي بتخدمها لو اتكلمنا
عن الوقت فاحنا هنا في قلب العالم عن طريق
رحله طيران مدتها 8 ساعات على الاكثر تقدر
توصل ل90% من مناطق العالم تقريبا اما لو
اتكلمنا عن التكلفه فالمدى الزمن القليل
ده معناه انك مش محتاج دايما للطيارات
الضخمه والمكلفه اللي محتاجه تقعد 10
ساعات او اكثر في الجو ده غير ان كفاءه
استهلاك الوقود بتقل كل ما الرحله قعدت
فتره اطول وده معناه طبعا تكاليف زياده
واخيرا بالنسبه للطرق والمراكز لو بصينا
مع بعض على الخريطه هنلاقي ان اقصر للسفر
بين المراكز الرئيسيه في العالم معظمها
بيمر طبيعي من وعلى الشرق الاوسط النقطه
الاهم بقى ان الحكايه بالنسبه للشركات
الخليجيه مش حكايه سفر وطيران بس دبي مثلا
استغلت موقع الاماره وخدمات طيران
الامارات علشان تجذب الناس لزياره دبي
وشراء عقارات ومساكن وتاسيس شركات وده كان
ضمن الاسباب الرئيسيه في طفره النمو
الضخمه في البلد اللي ارتفع عدد سكانها من
250 الف شخص سنه 1980 لاكتر من اربعه
مليون في الوقت الحالي لو بصينا على قطر
هنلاقي الهدف انها كانت عايزه تمتلك اسطول
جوي مدني ضخم ممثل في شركه طيران عالميه
باعلى المواصفات تكون جزء من قوتها
الناعمه وجزء من تعريف العالم بها عن طريق
تحويل العاصمه الدوحه على المدى الطويل
لمركز مهم للانتقال والتجاره والاعمال وده
بالفعل اللي حصل ونقدر نشوفه ببساطه في
تطور الشركه المذهل على مدار 30 سنه
تقريبا من تاريخ اطلاق سنه 1994 ثم اعاده
اطلاقها سنه 1997 وده ادى مثلا وبدون
الدخول في التفاصيل لمعدلات نمو مدهشه في
العشر سنين الاولى ونقدر نشوف مكان الشركه
حاليا في العالم من خلال تتبع جائزه عالم
الطيران الارفع ولا الخطوط الجويه القطريه
شبه مسيطره عليها من 2011 ودي السنه اللي
فازت فيها بالجائزه لاول مره وخدتها لحد
لحظتنا دي سبع مرات اخدهم السنه اللي فاتت
2022 طيب بعد ما فهمنا بشكل مختصر جدا
لشركات الطيران الخليجيه نجحت وبعد ما
نقدر نقول ان شركه طيران الرياض الجديده
هيكون عندها فرص نجاح مماثله خاصه مع
الامكانيات الكبيره المتوفره نسال سؤال
مهم بقى هل السعوديه عملت شركه طيران
علشان تنافس جيرانها الخليجيين وتقطع
عليهم حضراتكم هتلاقوا الروايه دي هي
الغلبه في الاعلام الاوروبي والامريكي
للاسف لكنها مش حقيقيه ولا دقيقه صحيح
دخول شركه ط جديده في المنطقه هيوشعل
المنافسه وهيخلي كل شركه تحاول ترتقد
معاييرها وخدماتها وده طبعا في مصلحه
المستهلك لكن السعوديه مش عامله الشركه
علشان تنافس جيرانها والموضوع اكبر من كده
بكتير السعوديه بتخطط انه بحلول سنه 2030
السياحه هتساهم بعشره في الميه من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للبلد وتضيف ما لا يقل عن
مليون وظيفه جديده وده بيشمل سياحه
الدينيه متمثله في الحج والعمره وزياره
الاماكن المقدسه والسياحه الطبيعيه في
المنتجعات الصحراويه والمشروعات السياحيه
الكبيره على البحر الاحمر اللي المملكه
خططت ابنها وطبعا السياحه الاثريه في
المناطق التاريخيه في المملكه زي محافظه
العلا طيب السعوديين فين حاليا من الاهداف
الطموحه دي هما لسه في بدايه الطريق
البيانات الرسميه لحد سنه 2022 بتقول لنا
ان اجمالي عدد السياح الاجانب والمحليين
في المملكه بلغ 93 ونصف مليون منهم 77
مليون سائح محلي و16.5 مليون سائح اجنبي
مجلس السياحه والسفر الدولي قدر اسهام
قطاع السياحه والسفر في المملكه بسته ونصف
في الميه من الناتج المحلي الاجمالي سنه
2019 ففي طريق طويل السعوديه محتاجه تقطعه
علشان تحقق اهدافها الطموحه دي لكن المؤكد
انه من 2019 تحديدا والمملكه بتشهد
انتعاشك كبيره وجزء كبير من الانتعاش ده
كان بفضل خطط التحفيز السياحي الكبيره
اللي بداتها وقتها وشملت خطوات زي اتاحه
التاشيره السياحيه الالكترونيه لمواطني
اكتر من 49 دوله بتمثل تقريبا 80% من
الانفاق السياحي حول العالم وهي موطن ل75%
من المسافرين في الرحلات الفاخره برده
التسهيلات دي كملت مع اصدار عدد اخر من
التاشيرات المرنه اللي بتسهل سياره
المملكه لكل الراغبين سواء الاعداء العمره
وزياره الاماكن المقدسه في مكه والمدينه
او لحضور الفعاليات السياحيه الترفيهيه طب
ايه علاقه الكلام ده بشركه الطيران
الجديده البديهي ان الاهداف السياحيه
الطموحه دي
يتطلب منظومه نقل قويه علشان تنقل السياح
المستهدفين من والى المملكه وكمان بين
المدن السعوديه المختلفه وده اللي خلى
المملكه تطلق في مايو 2022
استراتيجيتها الوطنيه للطيران اللي تعهدت
خلالها باستثمار اكتر من 100 مليار دولار
في القطاع ده بهدف رفع عدد الوجهات اللي
بيسافر لها الطيران السعودي لاكتر من 250
وجهه وزياده عدد المسافرين اللي بيسافروا
للمملكه او عبرها من 109 مليون في 2019 ل
330 مليون مسافر بحلول 2030 وبتستهدف برضو
30 مليون مسافر ترانزيت الاهم من ده كله
ان المملكه بتاكد ان شركه الطيران الجديده
هتضيف لوحدها عشرين مليار دولار للناتج
المحلي الاجمالي السعودي وهتولد اكتر من
200 الف وظيفه مباشره وغير مباشره طبعا
الارقام دي ضخمه جدا خصوصا لما نعرف ان
عدد الوجهات الحاليه للطيران السعودي اقل
من 100 وجهه في حين ان عدد المسافرين
مليون تقريبا بسنه 2019 يعني احنا بنتكلم
في ثلاث اضعاف كل حاجه لكن هنرجع وناكد ان
تجارب الاشقاء الخليجيين في الامارات وقطر
بتخلينا متفائلين ان الاهداف دي او على
الاقل جزء كبير منها ممكن يبقى قابل
للتحقيق وفي الواقع لو دققنا النظر شويه
هنلاقي السعوديه عندها ميزه رئيسيه مش
متوفره لجيرانها المحليين وهي السوق
المحلي القوي بسبب عدد السكان الكبير
نسبيا يعني بنتكلم عن 35 مليون نسمه
والمسافات الكبيره بين المدن الكبرى اللي
بتتجاوز ال 1500 كيلو متر في كتير من
الاحياء وده ممكن يخلق طلب داخلي قوي على
الطيران وفي النقطه دي تحديدا البيانات
بتقول لنا ان المعدلات النمو في حركه
الطيران المحليه عالميا كانت اكبر من
الحركه الدوليه خلال العشر سنين الاخيره
وده بيخلي السوق المحلي في المعتاد محرك
قوي لاي شركه طيران ناجحه كل ده معناه ان
السعوديه عاوزه توسع سوق الطيران وتخلق
شرائح جديده العملاء خاصين بها بالظبط زي
ما دبي عملت قبل كده وده لو اتحقق ممكن
يفيد سوق الطيران في المنطقه كله بما في
ذلك الشركات الخارجيه التانيه وهنا نيجي
لسؤال اهم ازاي السعوديين ناويين يحققوا
الاهداف دي حتى الان الخطه التفصيليه مش
واضحه لكن في خطوط عريضه ممكن نشير لها في
الوقت الحالي السعوديه بتخطط يكون في
مركزين رئيسيين للسفر في البلد بتخدمهم
شركتين طيران كبار المركز الاولاني هيكون
في جده اللي بتعتبر بوابه دخول مكه
المكرمه وده هيركز بشكل رئيسي على رحلات
الحج والعمره واللي هيركز على ده هتكون
شركه الطيران الجويه السعوديه الحاليه اما
المركز الثاني والاكبر فهيكون في الرياض
وهتتولى تحقيق اهدافه شركه طيران الرياض
الجديده وهيركز على السياحه والسفر الدولي
وخلونا نركز اكتر شويه مع طيران الرياض
المملكه تعاقدت مع اتنين من الاسماء
المخضرمه جدا في عالم الطيران وهم
البريطاني توني دوجلس الرئيس التنفيذ
السابق لطيران الاتحاد واللي منصب المدير
التنفيذي للشركه الجديده بيتر بيلو رئيس
العمليات السابق في شركه ايزي جيت
البريطانيه واللي هيتولى نفس منصبه بس في
الشركه الجديده ودول تقريبا هيقوموا في
طيران الرياض بنفس الدور اللي قام بهجان
في دبي في طيران الامارات في التمانينات
لكن على نطاق اوسع وبامكانيات اكبر بكتير
الواضح كمان ان مطار الرياضه المعروف
حاليا بمطار الملك خالد الدولي هيكون
محوري في الخطه السعوديه وهيلعب نفس دور
المركز اللي بيلعبوا مطارات دبي والدوحه
بالنسبه لطيران الرياض والخطوط القطريه
يعني الطائرات السعوديه هتجيب المسافرين
من كل حته في العالم للرياض ومن هناك
هيسافروا لوجهتهم النهائيه سواء الاماكن
السياحيه في المملكه او المدن اللي هم
رايحينها في اسيا اوروبا وامريكا وده كمان
هيخلي بالتبعيه مدينه الرياض نفسها تتحول
لمدينه مهمه مركزيه في المنطقه والمسؤولين
السعوديين على راسهم ولي العهد محمد بن
سلمان بيتوقعوا ان عدد سكانها هيرتفع من 9
مليون نسمه حاليا
حسب احدث تقديرات السنه الحاليه 2023 لما
بين 15 و20 مليون نسمه على سنه 2030
بالنسبه لمطار الملك خالد فهيتم دمجه ضمن
مطار اوسع في العاصمه الرياض باسم مطار
الملك سلمان الدولي على مساحه 57 كيلو متر
هيتصمم من البدايه علشان يكون مركز كامل
للطيران مسود بست مدارك متوازيه وقادر على
استيعاب 120 مليون مسافر بحلول سنه 2030
وده اكتر ب 50% من رقم 80 مليون مسافر
اللي حققوا مطار هيترو الشهيد في لندن في
ذروته سنه 2019 واكبر من الساعه القصوى
لمطاري دبي والدوحه اللي سعتهم 92 مليون
مسافر وخمسه وخمسين مليون مسافر على
الترتيب ده غير ان المملكه بتستهدف ان
المطار يستوعب 185 مليون مسافر بحلول سنه
2050 المطارات التانيه في المملكه برده
مؤكد هيكون لها نصيب من التطوير وعلى
راسها مطار الملك عبد العزيز الدولي في
جده تطوير المطارات مش هيكون هدفه سياده
ساعاتها وقدرتها على التعامل مع اعداد
اكبر من ركاب ولكن كمان انشاء مراكز
لوجستيات بمواصفات عالميه المؤكد كمان ان
منطقه المنتجعات الجديده على البحر الاحمر
وخليج العقبه هيكون لها نصيب خاص من
الاهتمام خاصه بعد ما يتم افتتاح مطار
البحر الاحمر الدولي بساعه مليون مسافر
خلال السنه دي 2023 وده لان السعوديه
هتطلق شركه طيران خاصه لخدمه مدينه
نيويورك بشكل خاص والمشروعات السياحيه على
البحر الاحمر بشكل عام ومن المقرر انها
تبدا عملياتها السنه الجايه 2024 طيب كل
ده كلام جميل ولكن في ظل الصوره الواعده
دي لشركه طيران الرياض الجديده لازم نتكلم
عن واحده من اكبر الازمات اللي واجهه
شركات الطيران مؤخرا واللي اتسببت فيها
جائحه كورونا الحقيقه ان الامور في قطاع
الطيران ما كانتش في افضل احوالها بين
2019 و2022 تحديدا بسبب ازمه كورونا اللي
وصلت ما بين 40 وخمسين شركه طيران حول
العالم لحافه الافلاس
على اعاده هيكله واسعه ولو اتكلمنا بشكل
اخص على الشركات الخليجيه فالخبراء
بيوصفوا عمليه الاغلاق المصاحبه لجائحه
كورونا بانها كانت اشبه بخيار نووي وده
كان للامارات تحديدا اللي كانت بتقفل
صناعه بتشكل 13% من الناتجها المحلي
الاجمالي وبتدعم اكتر من 800 الف وظيفه
بالنسبه لدبي بالذات الامور كانت ماساويه
اكتر من كده بكتير لان صناعه الطيران
بتشكل ربع الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للاماره
تقريبا محطه قطر تاثرت وده لان قطاع
الطيران كان بيشكل 11% من ناتج البلاد
الاجمالي المعاناه دي خلت شركات الطيران
الخارجيه تضطر لخيارات مؤلمه شملت تقليص
اساطيلها الجويه وتسريح الالاف من موظفيها
لتقليل الخسائر والقدر الاكبر من الالم ده
تحملته شركه طيران الاتحاد اللي اضطرت
لتقليص اسطولها الجوي من 200 طياره ل72
طياره بس وخفض عدد مو من 29,000 ل 8500 بس
الواقع الحالي لقطاع الطيران اللي لسه
بيكافح لمواجهه اثار الجائحه دي مخلي بعض
الخبراء متشككين فانه في مكان لشركه طيران
رابعه كبيره جديده في الخليج لدرجه ان
رئيس الاتحاد الدولي للنقل الجوي والرئيس
السابق لشركه الخطوط الجويه البريطانيه
حذر من ان اي مطار رئيسي جديد لازم ما
يكونش قريب من دبي او الدوحه لانه شايف
انه في ظل الوضع الحالي للصناعه فالمطار
الجديد غالبا هيفرض عليه انه يكون منافس
للمطارات دي بصوره او باخرى قدره الشركه
السعوديه الجديده على تحقيق ارباح برضو
هتكون تحدي كبير بسبب المنافسه الكبيره
وبسبب مصاريف التشغيل المرتفعه في البدايه
لكن الخبر كويس ان المملكه عندها القدره
الماليه الكافيه انها تصبر على مرحله
تحقيق الارباح دي وتفكر على مدى ابعد شويه
الهدف حاليا هو ابراز صوره المملكه واغراء
الناس بزيارتها سواء بهدف السياحه او
كنقطه عبور لوجهتهم رئيسيه وبطبيعه الحال
تحقيق النجاح في ده هيتبعوا تحقيق الارباح
على المدى البعيد لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي
وفي النهايه كالعاده عندي سؤال لحضراتكم
يا ترى تتوقعوا ان شركه طيران الرياض
السعوديه الجديده تحقق نجاح كبير زي
اخواتها الخليجيين ولا المعوقات هتخلي
التجربه المره دي اصعب هتابع كل اجاباتكم
في التعليقات هي شركه عالميه مقرها في
روسيا بتامن 400 مليون مستخدم و240 الف
شركه في 200 دوله حول العالم هتلاقوا رابط
تحت الفيديو في تعليقات فيسبوك لخدمات
الامن السيبراني اللي يقدروا يساعدوك
ويحموا اعمالك بها ويا ريت تشتركوا في
القناه زي ما اتفقنا ولو عجبتكم الحلقه
تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكوا
لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن نستفيدوا
سلام
[موسيقى]